I want to talk about orchestration of
microservices today quick Paul quick
Paul who is doing micro-services already
so almost of you who's doing so uh let's
see if you have an overlap
nobody Oh nobody everybody Stewie
micro-services awesome
I actually don't go into the into the
definition of microservice as much and
that actually don't care too much of
these are really like microservices how
big they are if this is so of these are
just independent components if you're
doing ddd it might be aggregates if
you're doing serverless it might be
functions or whatever it is the the
basic idea here is and what's important
is you have these kind of small like
very autonomous things or services which
normally have their own database which
normally have an own process like an own
golang process or it's probably a java
program or whatever it is so it's very
separated normally you have it a
dedicated team caring about that which
is normally the reason why doing that
because you want to scale up the
development so that's the setting where
we're working in and what you can see
and what we already saw over a couple of
customers is that if you if you go down
that route you end up with quite a lot
of services normally and there the
number of services is growing bigger and
bigger and the complexity shifts
actually from developing like the single
service which gets far more easier to
how these service collaborate in order
to do something useful and that's what I
basically want to talk about today this
is a lot about communication so these
services need to communicate with each
other in order to do something if you're
taught and it's remote communication we
are talking about distributed systems in
a minute and that means we basically
have a couple of options to do this kind
of communication so the first one it's
like we're just doing like we request
response it could be rest
it could be G RPC all these kind of
things who is doing something like this
that's the majority of folks I think the
other thing you normally do is might be
messaging or might be venting like Kafka
RabbitMQ or something like that who is
doing that oh it's half half here that's
actually a good ratio normally it's like
8020 and then what so you see it looks a
bit bit weird on the slide so I made it
four-quadrant which is probably not not
complete but one thing which i think is
important when you reason about these
kind of things is that there are two
things you have to separate the first is
if you're running like synchronous
communication or asynchronous and the
other one is you're blocking or non
blocking so these are like the defaults
what you normally use but you can very
well do like blocking asynchronous
communication if you're using rabbit for
example you have some some call which
blocks until you get the response
message and that's kind of a blocking
way of using messaging and I actually
like to draw that on a slide because it
it emphasizes one point if you're using
like rest for example HTTP here in a
blocking manner you're going over the
TCP network with asynchronous again so
under the hood it basically does the
same thing it's just very transparent
for you and obviously you can also do
use like like like T RPC callbacks or
arrest callbacks in order to to work in
a non blocking manner with synchronous
communication but that's kind of a
groundwork and normally what what
customers ask is something like okay
these are a couple of these options and
and what would be a good place to be and
I normally try to avoid to answer this
question basically because it depends on
so much factors I think the most
important one very currently stands so
so what what's the the background you
have what do you already have in place
what you're familiar with which normally
so my experience is like 80% of the
people are somewhere here and it would
be really hard for them to go something
inventing because it's it's a very
different philosophy so I try to keep
out of that question but when people
really ask me okay what's your personal
opinion I I like to quote actually a
great quote from Todd montgomery martin
tom stand to go to yeah go to chicago
they said some corners communication in
the crystal-meth of distributed
programming and that feels like I mean
if you're doing a rest call it looks
like a local method you're you're
calling something you're blocking you
get a response it looks like a local
method it's so easy to do and someone
would get the feeling there there's much
much more complexity involved but just
this last time I do that the next time I
do better but this is lost and I doing
it so I I obviously have a tendency to
think it's good for for us as an
industry
to move downwards here which I'm pretty
happy if we are having half half here
but the thing is what I wanted to talk
about today is that independently what
you do do here you will have challenges
especially in these communication things
and I basically want to talk about a
couple of them that all of them there
are quite a huge broad range of
challenges you might have a couple of
them and obviously I can only like like
like draw on my personal opinion ated
view on that and therefore it's
important probably to know who I am so
my name is Ben Rica and I'm I would say
kind of the state machine guy workflow
engine guy so I've working I work with
virtual engines since more or less 15
years and for different customers
different industry I committed to you to
a couple of open-source workflow engines
I wrote that lovely book over there it's
also available in English or BPMN with
an ISO standard for drawing this kind of
workflow models so I'm pretty much in
that workflow engine space and that
means whenever I see customers they are
normally kind of having this kind of
virtual engine thinking at least I bring
that thinking to them and that means I
look at that today from a perspective
what I saw in the products and how these
kind of state machines basically how
state can help in order to to yeah to
solve a couple of these challenges
that's what I want to do today actually
that's only like like like one
perspective you can have so they are
much more but that's all we can do in 45
minutes
and I will because I laughs code so I I
don't like talks with the slides only so
I will do code we will look through a
couple of go examples and therefore I
have to use a tool I use the source
engine it's from the company I
co-founded so that's kind of a
coincidence but if you're looking in the
NGO space there's not much to find
there's there's something from uber
which is comparable and there are a
couple of other open-source engines if
you talk to them by arrested they are
also available from go so my my point
today is more like a conceptual thing
but I use it obviously a framework and
that's called CB CB IO that's open
source so everything I do you can do at
home so that's my plan for today if you
don't like that that would be the
perfect bomb
to switch the talk okay awesome so let's
let's let's do this so I start with the
synchronous communication like rest G
RPC that's a typical thing now we have
remote communication and this is the
metaphor I normally used for distributed
systems I like that very much I once
learned it from I think it was Jonas
Pony from from live band and if you look
at distributed systems or remote
communication there's the great paper
from Peter George might know that the
fallacies of distributed computing
pretty famous and the first one it's
actually here down there where is it
the network is reliable that's the
policy it is not obviously it is not and
that's why I use that picture so the
network if the the ocean the ocean is
really really rough I mean this is your
application that's probably your go
application there it's pretty nice you
have a heating you probably have
transaction management it's pretty cool
to be here but as soon as you open the
door you have the rough Network and
that's something you really have to care
about it's not abstracted from you you
have to care about I think go
programmers are kind of aware of that
much more than than other languages
where you have a lot of abstraction
around that but it's important to keep
in mind so make it excites me can
example let's assume I write a payment
service and let's assume that uses
another upstream service for charging a
credit card
that's hopefully imaginable if I do that
with a remote communication I have to
think about the situation when they when
the network is not available
it might be a hiccup it might be a
longer outage but for some reason the
network is not available so the big
question is what I do then the first
strategy actually as I ignore that
problem I it always reminds me when I
started programming I have no exact idea
one that was like 11 12 13 something
around that and what I did at the very
beginning is Visual Basic you probably
remember we're so basic it has one
awesome construct I never seen that in
other languages on arrow resume next if
one line causes an arrow just through
the next line don't care that's an
awesome thing but actually that's that's
why what would how I always imagined
but actually ignoring the problem can be
a good strategy if you're using it
wisely so I had a customer recently he
said okay we have that one call which
writes the statistics and we have a
problem with that like like one or two
calls normally a month they don't go
through and we don't write the
statistics but we have an easy
reconciliation job we're like running
one two quarter which is kind of okay
for us and then okay that's a good
strategy keep it that's perfectly fine
you just have to think about so
ignorance can be a strategy what's most
often used is actually wreaths rowing
the arrow and that's not a good strategy
that's really the worst strategy like
okay hey I have that Network error
here's know is your problem
because what happens if you have these
micro service architectures let's see
let's say the payment service gets that
normally you have another upstream
service like for example or the service
or whatever it is and that means you
basically have these kind of cascading
failures and as soon as you imagine like
a bigger micro service infrastructure
this leads to exactly these kind of big
fails you try to avoid so the you should
really put a lot of emphasis to keep
that error like as local as possible
because otherwise you end up with stuff
like that and and that from the United
that was a flight from from New York
back to Europe and I give a couple of
other talks and these talks I normally
always have examples from checking in
Airlines and I have a lot of exceptions
from different Airlines error codes and
this kind of thing that's awesome
actually and I collected that and since
then I'm always happy when I get these
exceptions when I'm flying so but that's
the best only United so far had a really
500 that's really bad that's really bad
you shouldn't have that so be responsive
as soon as you develop one service think
about this situation think about how to
handle these kind of errors ignorance
can be a strategy we throwing normally
not what could you do in that case a
typical strategy would be retrying as
soon as you do remote communication
normally you have retries I'm retries
are fine the only thing you have to
think about really hard something
called idempotency you probably are
aware of item potency item Ponzi means I
can call it a couple of times and that
doesn't matter
the big question is why it's so Keaney
you probably cannot see that Keaney
right it's pretty dark here um it's it's
Keaney and I I search for a good
metaphor for idempotency for years so if
you have one let me know I'm really
happy about that mine currently is at
zucchini why because it's a key eating
zucchinis idempotent I had a vegan time
in my life before I got kids like a
couple of month i vegan and there you do
pasta out of zucchinis like noodles out
of the zucchini with a special cutting
machine and the good thing is you can
eat as much as you want it doesn't
matter it's healthy you don't grow fat
can just if you forgot if you already
eat have in your your plate of zucchini
just eat another one that's idempotency
pasta is not good yeah okay it's that's
my metaphor if you have a better one let
me know I'm really would be happy but
it's so - keenie idempotent now if you
if you have that the credit card if you
just hand some like charge something
it's not idempotent if you have like a
transaction ID
it's idempotent because you can see okay
I already charge that I don't do it
again
very important idempotency is really
important but it's a basic thing but
still it's worth to think of it to talk
about that a couple of minutes anyhow we
are still in a distributed system so if
we do reach wise and the most retry
implementation I see they do a retry
like immediately for a network hiccup or
didn't go through try it again I know do
so perfect but you also have network
outages and we had a keynote today from
from somebody from stripe so imagine a
situation where this credit card service
is something like like stripe really an
external service from a company hosted
somewhere so it's probably over like
really the internet and it's probably
down for longer so that's what we see a
lot and that means like directly
retrying it doesn't doesn't solve the
problem and that's where a lot of
customers start to use something what I
call us
eight full retry and that means I can
retry for not only like immediately but
like in a minute and probably have an
increasing interval and like five
minutes hour four hours depending on the
scenario and that normally makes your
service again much more robust if you
have like an API defined here where they
say okay we do the payment for you but
give us like an hour and then we do it
for sure even if you have network
problems you avoid these kind of
cascading failures it's a change in how
you see the service you probably fall
back if you're aged thinking in HTTP
from like I always get a two hundred
okay I probably get a two hundred to
accept it so I talk to you later these
kind of things that's why the
synchronous communication to crystal
meth so if you prepare for that you get
a much stronger architecture here so
that's a straight full retry normally if
I proposed something like stateful retry
the next question is Lai okay how we do
that that state state somehow ugly I
mean state handling we can do that yeah
we have this persistent I call it
persistent thing normally it could be an
entity database table it could be a
document in document store it could be
if you're probably not in go actors are
not that fencing your thing but if
you're using like scholar stuff it could
do an actor in a kaorun so there there
are loads of possibilities to have
something persistent but the problem is
it's it's quite a lot of effort because
you have to do it if you're running for
example if you're moving towards server
list having stayed it's kind of a
problem so it's not that easy to have
like stateful services as it is to have
stateless services so it's quite some
effort and then if you want to do the
retrying you probably have to have a
scheduler you have to have probably
operating you have to see if there are
errors popping up somewhere and these
kind of things so a lot of things you
have to build around that and that's why
a lot of people actually are backing up
backing off that and saying hot potato
pattern I I just we throw the arrow
before it start doing all that stuff and
that's where I'm these kind of workflow
engines get it handy that's what we
currently do in a lot of scenarios which
are really just about like synchronous
communication
in order to do retry this and I want to
when I use that as an opportunity for
some code the first time so what I said
earlier UCB that's not source product
cbio you find that yourself if you like
and how it works is you start up broker
that's a workflow engine let's say this
is written in Java so it's not like
native goal but Java it's easy to start
up it can have it as a docker image if
you like and then you have your
application and that could be like
basically everything so currently we're
having a native Java in the native go
client so I use the native go client
here and then you define like a workflow
model and that's what I said earlier
using BPMN it's an ISO standard so it's
kind of not a proprietary thing it's
pretty well known in the industry to
define this kind of flows like for
example I do something and then I will
show that in a minute I can also define
like things like retries timeouts and
these kind of things I define the model
here I deploy the model basically on the
broker the broker has to know it and
then I can run instances of that and
whenever I have something like do
something it's basically I publish I
subscribe to that from my own
applications I have an handler the
callback handler in in written and going
this in this case to do the work so it's
actually pretty easy so what does that
look like so what I have here is that
readable from the back awesome ok so I
have this is the version which probably
you all know I I do something like an
HTTP server I just have one endpoint
it's very easy demo to be honest I
listen to that and what's the endpoint
do and we basically read some data from
from the request then it charges the
credit card that does an upstream HTTP
call hang on hey there we are
and that basically does an HTTP POST so
that's the thing you probably already
who has programmed something like this
before
ok quite a lot of so when I call that
and I have that running here so I have
iya and I have
I call it a stripe fake service so
that's just an HTTP server which does
that payment I need that in order to
shut it down whenever I when I want to
simulate Network era and then I have
this so I say go run man go yeah Thank
You Venus hang on a second and then when
I do do a call it basically go through
that's I do an up street credit card
payment that's pretty boring if I shut
it down what happens should be also
pretty obvious like a test question if
you already have you're still awake
after lunch what happens
oh come on the upstream service is not
available I just shut it down obviously
yeah you should get an exception and
that's a 500 in this case because I
haven't done anything about it so that's
what we want to avoid and the next thing
I go I can do I go in the next version
here so I changed the main class I still
start the HTTP server I still have the
handle HTTP request that didn't change
but what did I do
I need something I need basically a
connection to the broker so this is how
it looks like it's just import the CB
broker I have a new client nothing very
fancy here actually and then I register
on the callback so I say I want I want
to do something this is the method you
should call whenever something is on the
charge credit card topic what's the
charge credit card topic there's the the
workflow definition fly within there I
can open that with a modeler that's BPMN
that's how it looks like and there what
you can see is whenever I have a
so-called service task I do something
and there I define it we call it topic
name so there's this charge credit card
should do that and the charge credit
card directly relates to this so this is
how this is connected and then I can
define like other things like a retry
strategy and this kind of thing so
whenever this doesn't work what should I
do and these kind of things
this basically have the callback the
back basically than thus the HTTP call
which already had before so it doesn't
change much there are a couple of things
in order to read the data which will get
easier in the next version of the of the
go client we still have to mess around a
bit but it's not not really complicated
there and then I can say basically the
workflow engine okay this didn't work
all this did work and then if it didn't
work it will retry and these kind of
things and if it did work it just moves
on and the only thing we have to check
when we now handle the request and we
charge the credit card what I did change
is now I don't do the HTTP call
immediately but I start a new workflow
instance so that's basically it the code
is on github so we can just walk through
that again probably a bit slower I know
I talk pretty fast most of the time but
I hope that gives you an impression of
the level of complexity what you need
that's my my goal here so it's not very
hard to do and if I have this the
behavior changes so let's start the hang
on a second the version three let's go
yes stripe service is still down now the
behavior changes whenever I hit the send
button it's still not there you see
something is going on here it retries
the call I haven't configured any delay
so it's just retrying the call
immediately my HTTP got back like a ok
it should be a 202 actually to be to be
fair I haven't hacked that so it's a
torrent okay so everything fine here but
the virtual hasn't yet called the
payment so what it can do in this kind
of engines is now you have the states on
where persistent and you can even look
into that so for example we have that
simple monitor it's called it's a very
easy application at the moment just to
look into the to the engine there you
can see okay what kind of instances do
they have okay this one was the last one
and then you see okay this one has an
error in the charge credit card because
we don't have retries left and you even
could dive into more more details and
depending on when they when the service
will go up again
let's do this then it can also have like
like additional retries either triggered
automatically with a delay or even
triggered manually so we have customers
also doing these kind of things after an
outage of a service they probably even
like in a batch start retrying like even
like 500 on of instances at once or
these kind of things so that's not a
problem so I retry that and this time it
went through and we should see the
charge on the credit card and the other
service so that's the basic idea here
and if you have these kind of things on
a wiki yeah we keep that you can even go
further so I have a second example also
in github don't go into too much detail
here looks more or less the same but I
extended the workflow model and this
also means this is again beep Amen ISO
standard so it starts here does the
first service it still does the second
like charging the credit card but first
it checks if the customer is already
credit and if it's then probably fully
paid by his credit then we don't charge
the credit card so that's also kind of
these kind of virtual models and it come
back to why I'm showing you that in a
minute and if you run this that's
version 5 don't think about too much why
version what's version 1 2 & 4 it's on
github
don't go run me so so I start this one
come on and no again I'm doing a call we
get it here we get the upstream service
and what you can see is I have a
randomizer here you probably let's see
if we get that on the screen there's a
remaining amount of 5 not sure if you
can see that yeah some some are nodding
and I have a randomizer so if I do that
a couple of times I no remaining amount
so sometimes I have a remaining amount
sometimes not so I can do that a couple
of times a lot of fun and then for
example chests ooh to trigger
imagination what most of these tools
have is kind of a way in order to also
to look into these kind of statists
like okay now we have one running
instance we have 20 already done how
much of them went which way how often
did we have these kind of errors or for
example here so that's frequency in
numbers and that's both sorry and that's
duration so how long did that take which
in this case is really boring but it
could be like if it's a real remote
services could be pretty interesting and
that means you get a lot of kind of also
data kind of knowledge out of these kind
of things okay so there's the github or
URL I also probably tweet about that
later on so that's easy to find if you
look at these kind of architectures and
if you do that really unlike like Wemo
dress calls what a lot of people ask the
next thing oh workflow engine for our
rest calls we do like millions of them
does that really work and that's the the
cool thing so if you look at CB online
you will see that it's currently not yet
released we didn't yet release a 1.0 so
we have another open source engine which
is pretty mature but we rebuild a new
engine from scratch and that's really
based on a lot of a lot of concepts you
have in distributed systems which you
probably know from tools like Kafka
Cassandra in order to make things really
scalable so we really can scale the
broker we don't need any any database
underneath we were doing own event
streaming on disk we do consensus
protocols so we really have a linear
scale there and we currently make tests
on on Amazon and there you can easily
run up to one or two or three million
virtual instances per second so that's
that's not the showstopper anymore and
you can obviously also scale up the
clients and you could have like
different go programs for the different
pieces in that virtual model also in
order to scale it up so there are
various things to do and that works
pretty well and that's also yeah what
what brings it to a level where you can
use these kind of tools for also these
kind of let's say low-tech problems
because if I say workflow engine most of
the time people think of like oh you
have this big business process like
drawn on the wall like this huge order
process thingy but it could be like
tiny little flows where I showed you
which we are going at and then state can
help you to solve a couple of the
challenges you have there yeah and what
I said we did a couple of measurements
and for example this is the rate of
events written per second so we are more
or less in the same league of Apache
Kafka so just to give you an impression
of scalability and then what what do
people do with that customer so we we're
going into the first pilot projects with
big customers and they either use that
from within one micro service so you
could have like one micro service and
say okay this there I have a stateful
problem like retrying or probably like
in something more complicated then I
just use a workflow engine there and
then autonomy within micro service
architectures probably another service
has also state problem but he solves it
differently or he uses a different
product so that's fair it's perfectly
fine so that's what a lot of people are
doing but we also see architectures
where customers start to use it as kind
of a word distribution kind of this more
central thing which is let's say more
unusual especially if you're into that
dumb pipes smart endpoints thinking
what's also very interesting to look at
that and from this perspective okay
awesome and we're using VP man that's
what I said people that's actually it's
pretty dark right you cannot see that
that's a really good book you should buy
that but it's a it's a BPM and and
that's an ISO standard and I really love
people man and I'm currently a lot of
developers don't know beef a man who
knows ppm and that's like 20 people
probably more of you should know beep m
and why it's it's a really good language
it's a really good language to express
these kind of state machines and it's
really mature so we worked on the bpmn
standard for like over the last that say
10 to 15 years I worked with a couple of
different languages and a lot of this
experience also is non-b per man so we
can express a lot of problems in BPM
pretty good it's wide spread worldwide
iso standard and it's easy to understand
and not only for developers like who
probably like jason Yunel files but also
for
like operations people which can
normally look into these kind of things
or probably in business people look into
the kind of things okay but don't wanna
want to go too much into the tools so
back to the concept we are having that
network error we're having the payment
and the credit card right you remember
that I hope now we have that retrying
probably you're the same machine
workflow engine normally what you still
do is something like when the retries
doesn't work for a couple of like for a
certain period of time we give up right
make sense again now we have to think
about distributed systems and one
characteristic of distributed systems is
that whenever you have a network call
and you get a network error you have no
idea if you either have never reached
the service provider if you have reached
him and then probably the the process
bursts were killed or the Machine got
killed or whatever or if it has
processed your request and the response
got lost and that's actually independent
if you're doing like G RPC arrest or if
you do messaging and don't get the
response message so you cannot
differentiate these situations you have
no idea and that means especially if
you're doing payment it's probably not
such a good idea just to raise like a
payment field but you probably have
charged something that's bad situation
to do customers don't like that and so
that means you even have to think about
cleaning up cleaning up could be
different things like for example okay
I do refund or I call a certain cleanup
a method on the service or whatever it
is but you have to do that and again you
have to do it reliably because think of
the network whenever you call it it
might not be available because you you
try to charge it it was not available
this way you ended up here but now you
have to make sure you didn't do it and
these kind of things again in some
situations ignorance might be okay
because you say okay that doesn't matter
for money normally it's not
so you have to really decide make a
conscious decision on the on the on the
case you have the table but it's
important to have these and from my
perspective to have these kind of
strategies in your mind okay awesome so
that was more about synchronous
communication let's move to the
asynchronous there's actually it's a
highlight there you probably don't see
that you have the same challenges
actually there and there especially if
you're using Kafka we're having a lot of
customers currently using CAF count on
also talking at the Kafka summit later
this year and what they normally have
they have problems like okay we are now
using this message system and we
probably wait for an asynchronous
response but it's really hard for us to
track if we get that and to track if
something got lost to do something about
that if it wasn't done on the pier
because we have no idea what he does we
just send out the message and then it's
gone which is for a lot of problems not
okay and then again you can do something
like like also timing
that's against aid you have to to wait
for for some time it might be five
minutes might be an hour might be two
days that depends on the use case but
you have to wait some time and if then
nothing happens if I don't get the
response message the acknowledge message
whatever it is I have to do something
else but only then and that's actually
hard to program without having the state
machine without having scheduler these
are kind of things which are really hard
and then you can even do more stuff
that's what I said the payment is quite
rich you can do something like and this
is the so called non interrupting timer
so this one interrupts the waiting I
just give up I don't do it anymore but
this one doesn't interrupt I do
something in parallel and and probably
just just retried and this kind of thing
so it can do a lot of cool things there
you can have wait you can wait for
multiple messages aggregation of
messages you say okay I need a B and C
and when I have all of them I can move
on and if that doesn't happen within a
certain time I have to do something else
you can do like resequencing this
enterprise integration patterns you can
do all of them which which Khan
state contained state can be very well
expressed with these kind of machines
and then for example what we do in CB
that's also pretty interesting
we were buffering messages so whenever
you have an incoming message you can
define a time to live and say okay this
message and it can if it can be
correlated to to process or if it can
start a new workflow instance within
like whatever 2 hours then it's fine
otherwise we discard the message or we
raise an incidence all those kind of
things okay cool so these are
communication challenges that's one part
of the story another part actually my
favorite part
consistency challenges as soon as you
have multiple services and you have that
in all of these architecture independent
of communication you have consistency
challenges because if you have like two
services and what you don't have you
don't have transactions asset
transactions they're gone in this world
there were some attempt to do really
distributed transactions but at the
moment there's nothing what really works
in real life the best quote there is
from patel who said grown-ups don't use
distributed transactions and patterns
works at curly at Salesforce was at
Amazon wrote a couple of good papers
about that and one very easy example and
that's a real life example from a
customer very big car rental agency and
they're doing all they're not all but
most of their micro services current
lingo and they use Kafka law and they
have basic problems such as whenever
they consume a message from Kafka do
some business logic in a database emit a
message or an event that they did
something and then acknowledge the
message from Kafka that they that they
did it and they cannot do that in one
transaction and that's it's kind of a
not that easy problem because now you
have I don't go through all of the
possibilities you couldn't have
different possibilities in which order
you do the different things but
depending on what possibility you select
you have different problems either you
lose the message or you do things more
than once or you probably omit
Vence more than ones or you probably
delay emitting an event so there are a
couple of problems with these kind of
architectures which might be okay for
your use case but what they did not for
all but for some use cases they did
something which I see relatively often
in this scenario they write they do
something some business logic in the
database and then they have an own table
which is called like events to send or
something like that so they write the
event to send in the database now they
have a transaction a really asset
transaction for that committed and then
I have an own scheduler querying the
database table in order to see what they
have to send to Kafka and that's what
the that's one of the architects there
what he what he tweeted a soon after
actually so that's kind of you build
your own state machine with the kind of
things so that's not what he should do
you can solve also these kind of things
which a very simple state machine where
you say okay first to the business logic
that's transactional that's done and
then the workflow engine make sure that
it events is submitted even if whatever
the Kafka topic is not available or
whatever there so get these kind of
possibilities the same and that's even
probably the bigger topic for
consistency if you have multiple
services independently of if you're
calling them while messaging or by
arrest if you have two of them they will
not form a transaction you cannot roll
it back whenever service P now raises a
failure you already have done that and
that's done you cannot roll it back so
you have to apply different strategies
like for example if there's an error you
have to undo a I actually try to make it
to go away so that's one of the things
which really annoys me and go that you
always have that if but anyhow and so
you do an undo which basically means you
call another service to undo what you
already did that's not a rollback but
it's a semantical rollback it's an undo
there and it's also known as
compensation people men would have owned
on symbols for that but I used the
simple form here and it's also probably
known as the saga pattern not sure if
that
somebody rings a bell that's a really
important thing if you're in
microservices if you're in distributed
systems you have to think about
consistency in such a way you don't have
distributed transactions and that starts
with the first rest call very important
awesome let's spend like more or less
three minutes the last three or four
minutes on orchestration I I need to
talk orchestration and what I did now is
I showed you basically a couple of
different workflow models which is
normally always this kind of sequence
thing and that's orchestration whenever
I say workflow engine state machine
that's kind of an orchestration and if
you look at the microservice community
they're not that much in favor of
orchestration nowadays that started with
one article from Martin Fowler
he once said and the microservice
community community favors an
alternative approach smart endpoints and
dumb pipes that's very famous and you
probably know that and then he said okay
and then we are much in favor of
choreographing things and not using some
central Orchestrator and actually this
article and everything that followed
that that causes like I think a couple
of hours discussion every week for me
because that kind of is what most people
are really doing like choreography and I
make an example that you get what I'm
can follow me this is a customer Solano
you probably know them they're active in
you case well they're shaping clothes
and shoes and these kind of things
pretty big they're running the order
fulfillment process overall platform
that's why we know a lot of them a lot
what they do and they had talked about
that at a media of last year in Berlin
orchestrating a highly scalable
fulfillment process and the slides I
have are not what they are really doing
but it's related to what they're doing
and you can imagine it very simplified a
bit like this so if you have a check out
a payment inventory in the shipment
service and if you do it in a
choreographed approached independently
of communication could be event-driven
could be messaging could be rest could
be whatever it normally means that I
have some kind of peer-to-peer
communication
so either so if I want to want to have
the end-to-end process like paying
shipping and so on I started with the
checkout for example I buy something and
probably even Trevor would mean checkout
said something is ordered and payment
knows always something is ordered so I
have to collect money or the other way
around if you're more like
request/response the checkout probably
called payment and then payment does its
work and eventually knows all when
payment did the work I have to do
something and so on the force
this is a choreographed approach because
you don't have any central thing and the
problem is there are actually two
problems with that which I always see in
these kind of architectures the first is
you have no idea about the process
anymore so you simply cannot see that
you after a while you have to dig
through all the services which calls
what or you have to have some really
good tracing infrastructure to see
what's going on there so it's pretty
hard to reengineer the process which
normally means it's hard to change the
process and that's I was pretty happy
last year when Martin Fowler wrote
another blog post where he also wrote
about that because now people all the
people did these choreo craft approaches
and now you can see okay but the
dangerous that's very easy to make
nicely decoupled systems with event
notification for example without
realizing that you're losing skyed of
the larger scale flow and that sets you
in trouble so that's a bad place to be
and Netflix for example also a good
example they also started the conductor
it's also workflow engine basically a
scalable one also probably interesting
or worth to have a look at traditionally
some of these processes have been
orchestrated in an ad hoc manner using a
combination pop saw breast calls and so
on so forth however as the number of
micro services grow and the complexity
of the process increases getting
visibility into these distributed
workflows become difficult so that's a
problem you will face so from my
perspective and you can make a very very
prominent example if you want to want to
change the order of something in the
workflow you say probably oh I fetched
the goods before I wait for the payment
because I want to want to reserve this
stuff or one hour same-day delivery you
want to be faster with shipping it
you have I love that actually this is
the change you have to make if you're
doing rest calls you have to change each
and every service if your event to him
you have to change three or four
services that's not what micro services
are meant to be you want to have them
independently that's not decoupled at
all so that's the problem and the thing
is you have to extract that
orchestration logic you don't have to
have like what a lot of people think of
when they say orchestration is some
central whatever BPM workflow engine
which is kind of a huge monolithic thing
somewhere and that's not the case that's
the the arrow a lot of people made in
the past but you you have just the own
service for the orchestration logic for
the order and that my it doesn't have to
be but that might leverage a workflow
engine because it's again stayed for
because it's remote communication and
you probably want to want to have some
visibility that's fair but it doesn't
have to be that way and it's nothing
central and it's I think it's it's and
if Forex on the payment or something
with or with with the state probably it
has its own state machine very different
things so it's nothing like a monolithic
workflow thing it's really distributed
and that's important thing and that
means you have to balance orchestration
and choreography because depending on
the situation D either the one or the
other might be couple or decoupled this
thing and then you can run the virtual
engine either centralized or
decentralized that's a completely
different story depending on the tool
that might be easier or harder but it's
a different story so wrap up what I try
to make transparent hopefully that
worked a bit so every way of remote
communication has some challenges and
some challenges require stateful
components you need to have some kind of
state handling in there and if you do
then complex peer-to-peer communication
that can lead to a lot of problems if
you do in a purely choreographed
approach so you have to balance that
with orchestration that's what I trying
to get through I hope that was kind of
kind of okay if you have any question
I'm here the whole day afterwards so
approach me ask me anything I think
we're out of time
right yeah so thank you for coming
[Applause]